hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to you
know I was walking down the aisles of
the video store the other day and I
noticed something I haven't seen in
years
cartoon all-stars to the rescue
immediately a pool of disappointing
memories came flooding back to me and I
just knew I had to see this piece of
shit again now for those you who don't
remember this special I'll give you the
skinny in the early 90s ABC said they
were going to do a half-hour special
featuring kids favorite cartoons you
name it duck tails chipmunks Looney
Tunes Ninja Turtles the works when
you're a kid this is the equivalent of
like Elvis Meets The Beatles I mean the
world could just explode right there
so for weeks we've been waiting in
anticipation and finally the big day
came you know Saturday morning all the
kids are out that we're hyped as hell
and who do they get to start off this
groundbreaking event none other than the
goddamn President of the United States
himself oh my god George Bush is
starting this thing off oh my god George
Bush is starting this thing off that
can't be good he goes on and on about
how listening to your parents is
important and about how to maintain the
American family when your kid hyped up
as hell all you can hear is bad lab
Limon old person grab lap line keeping
you from your cartoons glad lab dad so
I've based on blabbing the show finally
begins it's just like the commercials
say everybody's there The Smurfs
ghostbusters Garfield L for some reason
I don't know maybe he snuck in the
background but bottom line everybody's
there it's unbelievable it's a dream
come true so now that all our favorite
cartoon characters are together in one
spot what are they gonna talk about
marijuana scusi marijuana did
design of the children's jessie
marijuana what what work is this son of
the Trib wants to see marijuana no no no
no this this is gotta be some kind of
stake it can't be the same marijuana
were thinking an unlawful substance used
to experience artificial highs oh my god
well why sign that the Chile's talking
about marijuana what kind of slap in the
face is that I mean science you know
what marijuana is Simon is 1d embodiment
of childhood he's from out on the
treatments for crying out loud
Jesus I feel so dirty sign of the
two-month Justin marijuana is there any
other American icon that can smash the
foundations of my childhood any quicker
watch gage a joint
why use Bugs Bunny know that join is
Bugs Bunny shouldn't know what it join
is it possibly knows where the joint is
that means he knows what drugs are it
Bugs Bunny knows with drugs enemies
Loretta lonely toons know what drugs are
at the wrestling toons know what drugs
are well that does explain Joe goddamn
much so if you haven't point together
yet
all our favorite cartoon characters that
we grew up with are coming together to
talk to us about drugs this is going to
be a long half-hour so it turns out the
specials not even about the cartoon
characters it's about a little twerp
named Michael who has a stinking drug
problem he sings to a new low when he
steals his sister Cory's piggy bank he
uses it to get more drugs which he hides
in a box a keeps under his bed and what
exactly does he keep in that box a silly
putty egg for turds and two cinnamon
buns glued together because hey he was
high and he thought was a good idea at
the time
Cory thinks about telling her father but
he's too busy being an alcoholic and gay
and the brawny man to make matters worse
Michael has followed around by this
obnoxious puff of smoke voiced by George
see Scott he needed me all his cares
went
okay that was lame but I like its next
speech a whole lot better this
individuality stubs a bunch of crap the
biggest bastard you wrote that stuff
about individuality don't know anything
more about real battle than they do
about fornicating now that's a puff of
smoke I can follow loser but tell me
where did this slippery slope of
marijuana abuse begin well luckily Bugs
Bunny has a time machine that's able to
show us I borrowed it from Shelly we
find out that Michael just wanted to fit
in and that's why he started smoking
marijuana in the first place and once
you listen to how he talks can you
really blame him
you guys cruising for lung cancer or
what somebody give that kid a joint
after that we get some more narc
speeches from the Ninja Turtles duck
tales and The Muppet Babies because when
I think drug abuse
I think Muppet Babies now after some
long-winded speeches the characters get
together and they do the most logical
thing they can think of they have an
intervention with an Alan Menken song
go on push eject protect yourself get
those drops are so boring if you
survived your suicide attempt the
special ends pretty much as you would
imagine it Michael gets off the drugs he
makes up with his sister the puff of
smoke disappears and his attentive
parents are none the wiser so what kind
of message are kids supposed to get from
the special that they smoke weed all
their favorite cartoon characters will
appear yeah it's a topmatch moral right
there and if you don't get off the drugs
these suckers can buy out in fact I was
shocked how cruel some of these cartoon
characters really are I mean look at
this they lock people in burning
buildings run them over with a roller
coaster blow them up drown them evenly
the poo gets his ass handed to him Jesus
these suckers are mean another problem I
have with this special is that everybody
cries at the drop of a hat
watch you see so okay what exactly are
these cartoon characters trying to tell
us there's nothing cool about a fool on
drugs fair enough I guess so the next
time you watch up doc is your life if
you don't cut it out okay you're
excellent just the way you are got it we
don't always see things the way they are
okay oh maybe everyone's got problems
keep it yeah I don't you just say no duh
you gotta believe in yourself you shut
up I heard you you use you lose okay God
you know I thought this would be really
cool but you know what this really blows
all my cartoon characters are fucking
narcs and me for crying out loud how
many times you have to hammer this shit
in if everyone was jumping off a cliff
would you go to maybe after seeing this
shit I mean for crying out loud you know
what the irony is I think that most of
these cartoon characters were on drugs
long before this special ever came out I
mean look at Garfield's always hungry
who's happy as hell daddy's hyped up on
speed and Michelangelo will listen to it
your brain must be like really
I even think our beloved president
smoked a doobie before he came out I
mean look at him he's looking at
Barbara's head like it's a giant
cheeseburger maybe I'm being too harsh
on this special after all they are
trying to get across a very moral lesson
drugs aren't your pal pal they're your
enemy a very sound point any objections
I make him feel good it's got me there
marijuana